stephen budianski correspondent for the
atlantic monthly discusses his new book
the bloody shirt terror after appomattox
he narrates the history of terrorist
violence in the post-civil war south and
the few courageous people who dared to
stand up for the rights of freed men
the event hosted by the rotary club in
vienna virginia is 35 minutes
stephen budianski
has written 12 books of history
science
and
and nature
he was a journalist with a u.s news and
world report for many years
he was their deputy editor their foreign
editor
and their national security
correspondent
he is a graduate of yale university
with a degree in chemistry
but he decided to go straight apparently
in history
stephen is going to be talking to us
today about his latest book
called the bloody shirt
so i would ask you to join me in giving
giving steven boutianski a warm vienna
rotary welcome
[Applause]
well thank you very much thank you for
that very kind introduction
i've always been a little bit leery of
introduction since the time i was on a
panel in the speak the chairman
introduced me by saying and next the
latest dope from washington
um thank you very much for having me
here today and thank you to c-span book
tv for being here today as an author i
can say they are a great institution
that have that is much appreciated by
those of us who try to make a living
writing books
history in the old saying is written by
the victors
and as early as the summer of 1865 there
were a few farsighted men who realized
that not only had the civil war not
truly ended with lee surrender at
appomattox that spring
but uh that the south was very likely to
emerge triumphant from the struggle to
come
in the prologue to my book i quote a man
named albion tourgee
who's really only a minor figure in in
my book but a man whose experiences i
found deeply affecting
tree had become a state judge in north
carolina during reconstruction after the
civil war
and quite fearlessly took on the ku klux
klan he defied local white opinion and
white social ostracism by empanelling
african americans as jurors
finding lawyers in his courtroom who
used the n-word
and many years later when the rest of
the nation had long forgotten the fate
of the freedmen
terge would become one of the founders
of the organization that was the
forerunner of the naacp
in 1879 feeling really thoroughly
defeated by the successful overthrow of
reconstruction by fraud and terrorist
violence
and by the effective disfranchisement of
black voters terge gave an interview to
the new york tribune
and he said in all except the actual
results of the physical struggle i
consider the south to have been the real
victors of the war i'm filled with
admiration and amazement at the masterly
way in which they have brought about
these results
the way in which they have neutralized
the results of the war and reversed the
verdict of appomattox as the grandest
thing in american politics
and terge noted something else too he
said not only was the south the real
victors but they had succeeded in
winning the struggle for memory
and indeed history would be
extraordinarily unkind to men like terge
who courageously fought on the losing
side of this struggle to secure the
fruits of victory from the civil war
northerners and white southerners who
joined political hands with african
americans would be vilified for
generations to come as carpet baggers
out to make a fast buck or low
scallywags and reconstruction would be
painted as a time of rampant corruption
and victim oppression by
of white southerners by federal bayonets
the phrase that probably appeared a
thousand times
in southern newspapers of the age
but you know this was no accident
because paralleling the guerrilla
warfare that i described in in my book
that was unleashed to bring about these
results that turget talked about
was really a concerted effort to rewrite
the history of this epic and justify the
crimes committed and so successful was
this rewriting of history that not many
people even today realize what to me is
still an astonishing fact which i quote
in my prologue
namely that three thousand
african americans and their white
political allies who in those days were
the republican party
3 000 were murdered in terrorist
violence in the south during this
10-year period
and that included close to 100 officials
who were assassinated state judges state
senators sheriffs mayors county
supervisors
and
most dramatically of all in 1875 and
1876 ten years after the end of the
civil war
there was a campaign of massive fraud
intimidation and violence openly carried
out openly boasted of in the white
newspapers of the day
by conservative white democrats to seize
power and put an end to black voting for
the century to come
interestingly one of the few
ex-confederates who roundly denounced
this southern rewriting of history about
the war in its aftermath was john mosby
now that's a name who's well known in
these parts of virginia mosby was of
course famous as a partisan rebel
cavalry man who hanged yankee soldiers
from trees and terrorized the enemy's
rear
but in the 1890s mosby was writing an
old friend of his an old comrade from
the civil war
one of his fellow confederate soldiers
and he said
i don't go to reunions because i can't
stand the speaking
and he was referring to the reunions of
confederate veterans and he said he was
fed up with what he called the
oratorical nonsense that was the staple
of speeches at such events and what he
was referring to was
the absolute standard speech at every
confederate reunion at every
white democratic southern political
rally of this era
which always said the civil war had not
been fought to preserve slavery but for
great constitutional principles that the
south had not committed treason but had
a quote perfect right to secede that was
the phrase always used and that the
south indeed hadn't even really lost or
been defeated but had simply been
overpowered by numbers which is an
interesting distinction i've never quite
got but
but mosby as i said was having none of
this and he would in this letter to his
old friend he said why not talk about
witchcraft if slavery was not the cause
of the war
he said i always understood that we went
to war on account of the thing we
quarreled with the north about i never
heard of any other cause of quarrel than
slavery and interesting too about mosby
was his unwillingness to play this game
of saying we had a perfect right or it
wasn't really about this or that and
he's like a man stood up and he said i
never apologized for anything i did
during or since the war he said i
committed treason and am proud of it
he said i am not ashamed that my family
were slave holders neither am i ashamed
that my ancestors were pirates and
cattle thieves
mosby thought it was the role of the
defeated to accept defeat and move on
and he supported grant for president
actually became a diplomat in the
american foreign service
but his was a voice in the wilderness in
the south and in fact because of his
views he found it
almost impossible to set foot in his
native virginia for many years to come
so unwelcome was he for saying these
things
well what i tried to do in my book was
to bring back to life some of the men
and women who courageously tried to
stand up against this wave of violence
who fought selflessly and honorably in
what was really america's first war
against terror to secure for the peace
what had been fought for and won on the
battlefields of gettysburg and bull run
that preceded it and who deserved to be
better remembered and some of the people
i talk about in the bloody shirt include
lewis merrill who was a
major of the the seventh cavalry who
brilliantly fought the ku klux in south
carolina really using the kind of
psychological methods and subtlety that
the army would later have to relearn in
future counter-insurgency wars
uh included delbert ames who was a hero
of the first battle of bull run he
became governor of mississippi
he brought good government public
education
equal rights for african americans
strict financial accountability to the
state government but he was overwhelmed
by a campaign of terror that stole the
election in 1875.
they include james longstreet who like
mosby was one of those freaks of nature
a uh
uh ex-confederate officer who believed
it was the duty of the south to accept
defeat long street you know was really
probably the most brilliant general of
the confederacy certainly the most
brilliant court commander but he'd be
vilified after the war for accepting the
rights of the freedmen and he he was
actually asked he had settled in new
orleans and he had
was asked by the local newspaper what
were his views on the civil rights act
and he uh made the mistake i guess you
could say of writing back and saying
he said the surrender of the confederate
armies in 1865 involved one the
surrender of the claim to the right of
secession that's that key point about
perfect right to secede he was saying no
we've given that up
he said two the surrender of the former
political relations of the negro by
which he meant not just the end of
slavery but the acceptance of african
americans as citizens
and
um three the surrender of the southern
confederacy and then really rising i
think to some eloquence longstreet said
these issues expired upon the fields
last occupied by the confederate armies
there they should have been buried
the soldier prefers to have the sod that
receives him when he falls cover his
remains
the political questions of the war
should have been buried upon the fields
that mark their end
and
um
the
the people i include in my book also
include prince rivers who had learned to
read and write while a slave
then his owner had fled with his
property from beaufort on the south
carolina coast when union troops seized
port
port royal island the first year of the
war
and when rivers owners stopped to visit
relatives in edgefield rivers promptly
saddled as masters best horse run 100
miles straight back through the
confederate lines right back to port
royal and enlisted in the union army
and within weeks there were wanted
posters flapping on the roadside between
charleston and the coast offering two
thousand dollars reward for his
recapture and rivers joined the first
regiment of what would come to be called
the u.s colored troops he became the
color sergeant and provost sergeant of
the regiment
and his colonel later wrote there's not
a white officer in this regiment who has
more administrative ability or more
absolute authority over the men they do
not love him but his mere presence has
controlling power over them which sounds
like the description of a sergeant if i
ever heard one
after the war rivers became a state
legislator in south carolina and a trial
justice in hamburg south carolina
hamburg is the place where a really
horrific massacre of a half dozen black
members of the state national guard
company took place in 1876 during this
election violence
that i talked about earlier
this incident the hamburg massacre is
really the climax of my book but it's
also i i should say i mean it's not only
a terrible and horrifying event in its
own right but it was the turning point
of the downfall of reconstruction in
south carolina because it unleashed
literally months of terror by literally
thousands of heavily armed white members
of so-called rifle clubs that
effectively seized the electoral
machinery by force in that year's vote
and put an end to black voting
until the civil rights movement of the
1960s
after the massacre in hamburg uh which
had been a black majority town with a
population of about 1200 uh the
population dwindled and declined and
then finally in 1929 two huge floods of
the savannah river destroyed what was
left of the town hamburg was right
across from augusta uh georgia which had
built levees which protected their side
so hamburg on the other side unprotected
was even more
at the mercy of the floods
now i knew nothing
was really left there to see hamburg
disappeared from the maps
all of the buildings were gone no one
lived there but
when i was down in south carolina doing
research for my book at the state
archives in the south carolinian library
i got in touch with a man named peter
hughes who i'd found thanks to the
wonders of the internet uh had done some
research on the history of hamburg peter
is an engineer and history is his hobby
and his main interest was actually a man
named henry schultz who was a german
immigrant who had founded hamburg back
in the 1820s and proceeded to carry on
this sort of amazing
commercial rivalry with augusta georgia
involving lawsuits and murders and
attempted suicides and all kinds of
crazy things it was like a one-man
battle against the larger town
across the river
but
the thing about peter was that
you know years ago i i was talking to a
historian at the air university and he
said you know
local historians he said are people who
know everything about the things that
don't matter and nothing about the
things that do
but peter was certainly a total
exception to this um he was very aware
of hambrick's subsequent history after
the civil war as a as a black town and
about the hamburg massacre and he'd
really read everything and knew
everything and he'd been over every inch
of ground there
so when i showed up at his doorstep he
handed me this laminated map he had made
in which he had taken the original plat
of hamburg from the state archives and
overlaid a google earth satellite image
so we could see the present-day terrain
and it was just incredible and and so
off we went exploring and we were able
to figure out where the building had
stood where the black militia company
had taken shelter and the bridge
abutment of the railroad which actually
was one of the few things that was still
there
where the white rifle clubs had opened
fire actually first with guns and then a
cannon they had brought from augusta
and we figured out the place where the
militiamen had been executed one at a
time after they had surrendered
and you understand there was really
nothing there there wasn't a foundation
not a house
the land had been derelict for decades
most of it was like overgrown jungle
and yet a few of what had been these
originally broad streets of this town of
this great dream that this german
immigrant had had 150 feet wide we're
still sort of maintained as these mowed
paths
and just to what would be i guess the
west end of the original town just in
the last 10 years or so a whole row of
fancy new houses had been built
this was made possible thanks to the
strum thurman dam upstream which has
regulated the flow of the savannah river
and we did find this one pile of debris
that had obviously been bulldozed up
clearing these new home sites and there
were a bunch of bricks in there and that
was the trace of
hamburg
there had been a state historical marker
uh for hamburg but that was gone uh and
even that had only mentioned its history
as a pre-civil war cotton center there
wasn't a word about the
african-americans who lived there and
held political office after the war and
there certainly wasn't a word about the
hamburg massacre
well then we drove over to north augusta
south carolina a few miles away now
north augusta is a very affluent town it
was founded around 1900
and at the it actually now incorporates
what was the site of hamburg within its
city limits
and at the very top of this broad and
beautifully kept main street there's a
triangle of grass and with fountains and
you stand there looking down on this
whole very prosperous need as a pin
community and at the center of this
triangle is an obelisk that was erected
in a in 1916
and the words engraved on it explained
that it's the memory of mackie
merriweather now meriwether was the one
white man who was killed during this
hamburg massacre killed either by
friendly fire possibly or when the black
militiamen finally decided to return
fire and defend themselves after half an
hour
before they were before they surrendered
and were massacred um
but uh in any case basically it was you
know it was one lucky accidental shot
that killed meriwether um because the
black militiamen never had a chance they
were outnumbered uh
by uh
you know hundreds of members of this
white rifle club
but this monument declares that
meriwether was quote the young hero of
what was termed not the hamburg massacre
but the hamburg riot
and the monument declares that
meriwether gave his life quote that the
supremacy of anglo-saxon civilization
might be assured
now you know it's it's hard to describe
the feelings that this leaves in a
person on the one hand there's a
rational side of one that says the
outrage of what was done
then of during this era of the thousands
murdered of the freedoms stolen of a
people sent back to near slavery is
surely a more significant fact than the
way the historical truth was
subsequently distorted and buried
and yet
the outrage of historical injustice to
the truth somehow strikes very deep and
maybe it's because we know today we
can't bring those people back to life we
can't give freedoms back that were
stolen to those who lived through those
terrible times and often died bitter and
crushed men we can't write wrongs that
are now history but we can recover the
truth and that's one act of justice we
still can do and quite simply my hope in
writing this book was to do a small act
of historical justice to rescue the
biographies of some courageous people
who fought for right even though they
failed
and to save their memories from the
vilification that they endured in their
lifetimes and for much of the century
after their death
and i think to remind us of the debt we
owe even now to people most of us have
never heard of
but who are at least a century ahead of
their time in fighting for the most
basic principles our nation has always
stood for
well thank you very much um i don't know
if we have time for a few questions but
i'd be delighted okay great yes sir
as i recall you mentioned long street
you recall after the war jubilee early
and others criticized him as the
uh as having lost exactly
was that before or after he made those
days after and in fact it's
it's a fascinating little bit of history
and historiography because
the first historians of the civil war
were mainly europeans who'd come
and were unanimous in their praise of
longstreet and lee himself uh said that
he was his ableist lieutenant
um and it was after lee died number one
and after long straight uh made these
statements in support of reconstruction
that the gloves came off and early in
particular um
was leading this charge
making these accusations that he was
late at second manassas and late at
gettysburg and particularly gettysburg
if he had attacked a dawn like he was
supposed to the confederacy would have
won it was all a lie and i mean it's
it's really absolutely clear that it was
fabricated and
uh latest scholarship i mean for at
least a half century has you know
affirmed everything long street said and
uh
and really his brilliance as a general
and it was it was pure politics i
shouldn't say it was pure politics there
was also an element that the virginians
wanted to glorify lee's name and so lee
was perfect and so they needed a
scapegoat and preferably a non-virginian
but mostly it was reconstruction
politics
yes sir an aside to that
uh long street's widow
i don't know which one but anyway yeah i
lived in mariella georgia where i went
that's right yeah high school and i knew
her
and it was interesting because she was
just
she really was sort of like a bag lady
is that right
very poverty-stricken really well you
know there'd been no statue of
longstreet anywhere until i think it was
1998 they finally
north carolina sons of confederate
veterans raised money to have a statue
of longstreet erected at gettysburg but
there'd been no
monument to him anywhere in the country
until then
yes sir
the uh area just to the west of us
prides itself as a mosby heritage yeah
area and i was knowing that he was
basically a guerrilla warfare
man i was rather unimpressed with that
uh yeah but i'm much more impressed with
what you said is there any movement to
include
what you have found in your research
into that
you know maybe clean up those
those sides a little bit and make them a
little more respectable yeah
you know it's interesting i feel like
we're on the cusp of
a change in our approach to the history
of this period they've been my book is
one of a number that have tackled
this era
and that have tried to i think correct
the historical injustices
and um
you know i've been impressed just
anecdotally on a number of local history
groups including in places like
edgefield south carolina which you
wouldn't think is you know a bastion of
sort of progressive thinking have been
very open
to expanding
the record expanding their understanding
bringing in the story of african
americans
the mosby heritage area i think the
short answer is no there's nothing yet
but uh you know i i think i think we're
heading this way and i mean as
a journalist as a writer there's nothing
that that appeals to me more than a
little bit of uh you know an anecdote a
a story of a man that defies the
stereotypes that makes us see things in
different ways and these letters from
mosby just i found so fascinating and so
gripping that here was a man who was
basically saying i'm not having any of
this party line
you know whitewashing propaganda i'm
just going to tell it like it is and
you're right you know
you don't see this very often you see
the dashing cavalier
the moonlight and magnolia's romance
about the the civil war in connection
with him as with so much else
yeah i grew up in georgia virginia and
was raised on the theory i can remember
my elementary school books it was all
about states rights yeah i remember
hearing much about being over slavery
when your research what did you find
pro and con on the state rights issue
well i mean the fact the matter is the
only right that was involved in states
rights was slavery and you know if you
look at
uh calhoun senator calhoun's speech on
the senate floor the other you know
phrase was northern aggression this was
a terrible thing the war of the northern
aggression well calhoun's speech on the
floor of the senate in the years leading
up to secession
he starts cataloging acts of northern
aggression every single one was about
slavery failure to enforce the fugitive
slave act in the north that was northern
aggression
failure to allow the extension of
slavery into the territories i mean it
was there wasn't a word about economics
tariffs nothing it was slavery slavery
slavery and you know the fact of the
matter is over the years this became
increasingly a code word we were
fighting for to preserve the
constitution as it was was was what you
heard a lot of southerners say in a
right after the civil war well that
meant the constitution that guaranteed
that slavery could not be abolished um
you know um that uh gave the uh
south over-representation in congress
and the electoral college by counting
blacks three-fifths but of course they
couldn't vote
um
you know um
i i think it's it's uh especially when
you see statements such as mosbys i mean
it really sort of cuts through all of
the face saving euphemism i mean the the
only state right that was at issue was
uh slavery and the enforcement of the
fugitive slave acts and so on
the economics of the time though that
the south uh
the money rested in the north
all the trade and so forth and and the
south was dependent upon the slaves for
economic land well you know that's a
source of great dispute and uh in the
1970s there was a huge contra tomp in
the historical world
with uh a theory being published
supposedly analyzing that slavery did
make economic sense and that's what uh
perpetuated it and then
there's been i think a lot of new
research which has questioned that um
you know i mean to me that that's um
um probably
a moot point in many ways
certainly subsequent history of the
south showed they weren't dependent on
slavery um and also it begs the question
a bit i was just reading this
fascinating history of the state of
virginia and the resistance you saw in
virginia which was quite typical of most
southern states in the 1820s 30s and 40s
to invest in the most basic sorts of
things which provide economic
diversification of railroads and other
kinds of infrastructure and the planter
class you know
in many states in the south really had a
grip on
government power and viewed all of these
things as a threat in south carolina i
mean it's fascinating pre-civil war
there was no direct collection of the
governor no direct election for
president
apportionment in the lower house was by
both property value and population
so the counties that had large
plantations basically were hugely over
represented
um and so
you know if
i mean to the extent what you what
you're posing is true it was also i
think you could argue a self-inflicted
injury there was no intrinsic reason
that the south could not be economically
have been economically viable without
slavery in those days
is there a story behind your title
yeah it is but it's so complicated every
time i try to tell it i get uh uh tied
in knots but it's in the prologue of my
book basically i'll try to do this in a
nutshell you know
one of the standard phrases it's become
a standard phrase in the american
political lexicon of waving the bloody
shirt and it means sort of a blow the
belt
appeal to demagoguery
and this was the line in the southern
press through all these time there'd be
these massacres there'd be these
outrages there'd be this acts of terror
and the northern newspapers and the
senate would have an investigation and
the south would say oh you're just
waving the bloody shirt and
the thing that fascinates me about this
is that well
you know even if that were true
you know there was no denying that the
blood was real i mean and who's was it
and how it got there and i think it it
so perfectly captured the sort of
inversion of of truth and the historical
revisionism that went on
in in the south and in many ways became
the standard histories probably all of
us grew up with
the result of the publication of your
book in north augusta has there been any
kind of a resurgence of interest in a
hamburg historic site before the
subdivision yeah
yeah well no this
was to me one of the most surprising and
way encouraging things
because i was just sent last month an
editorial from the um
i came over there was the aitkin or
north augusta newspaper saying
i mean really a very tough editorial
saying nobody really likes to talk about
what happened here in 1876. this
monument up here is an embarrassment
and saying we ought to do something
about this and we ought to mark the
site of hamburg and so uh and there's i
mean really saying that this is
basically honoring um what would be
called a hate crime today and uh and i
know there had been some sort of very
quiet effort maybe to get this monument
moved to the family grave site and the
nearby cemetery but i i think it
definitely has done something and you
know we'll see but um that's what i said
i think we're maybe on the cusp of some
things changing
yeah
on the other side of that was there any
did you sense any sense of sort of a
backlash
you know i was sort of confessed
dreading a little bit and uh and i i've
been uh happy to say except for two
white supremacist websites one of which
said they wanted to reopen andersonville
prison and send me there um
i i really have not felt any blow back i
felt you know
a lot of people saying this is an
important part of sort of the forgotten
history and we need to
you know be aware of this so that's been
good
yeah in your research did you see any
turning points where a different
decision had been made politically that
the war could have been averted
are you talking about uh the civil war
or or what happened in reconstruction
you mean well you could approach it from
both but i was thinking more of the
civil war
you know i think
i mean that's a hugely complicated
question that's part of the six you know
that's one of the 64 thousand dollar
questions in american history i my sense
is no um and um i think that
you know and essentially longstreet
himself said this that he said you
resort to war when all political options
have been exhausted
and he said for well 20 years there were
these attempts to reconcile and develop
compromises and it was attempting i
think to compromise and reconcile what
was fundamentally
irreconcilable and in particular
you know in the 1810s 1820s still the
generation of washington and jefferson
there was an attitude among at least i
think many of the leading men of the
south that slavery was an embarrassment
it was
maybe a necessary evil but it was an
evil and there was this feeling it's
going to go away it's got to go away we
don't know how to do deal with this
ourselves
but
there was this sense that this is the
direction we're going
by the 1850s and the early 1860s you
have a much more entrenched i mean
almost 180 degrees attitude of defiance
in the south of these pamphlets being
published often by religious leaders
saying slavery is sanctioned by the word
of god it's the greatest benefit to the
african race
it's the it allows this wonderful
society we've built it's been presented
as a positive good so when you have that
sort of
you know diametrically irreconcilable
views i think war was inevitable
my national neighbor was a big civil war
buff and he gave me a book i'm a
clergyman so the other day he handed me
a book about then the premise of the
book was that it was the clergy in the
south who maintained
that kind of uh
evangelistic enthusiasm to maintain the
war that was one of the cheerleaders
well certainly a component of that that
you can see i mean i it's probably over
saying to say it was the cause but it
was it was definitely a component
one more question
yeah
i just recently i'm having a senior
moment about today with tyler the book
but i just recently read a book about
black slave owners
yeah
[Music]
well you repeat that yeah
the question was about black slave
owners uh in the pre-civil war south
charleston in particular was one place
where this happened
charleston had a significant popu free
black population artisans tradesmen
craftsmen
in some cases it was
freed men purchasing members of their
family
from
their previous owners there were often
complicated legal barriers to actually
getting their freedom so this was a way
around that if you were prosperous
enough to earn some money you could buy
your wife from
the ex-owner and maybe not legally be
able to emancipate her but it would be
your property there were you know some
cases where clearly it was part of being
a well-to-do prosperous person imitating
the white society um yeah but i mean it
was not a large phenomenon ever anywhere
but yeah it is you know one of those
strange things in history
stephen thank you okay well thank you
stephen brunt stephen brought some books
today
over here on the table i'm sure he'd be
happy to uh sign them if any of you
would like to buy them and uh so i just
wanted you to know that and i want to
give you a little
momento of your visit to the rotary
thank you very much thank you very much
for coming
we're adjourned don't forget the board
meeting don't forget the board meeting
stephen budianski a former national
security correspondent has written 12
books about military and intelligence
history science and the natural world
he's also a correspondent for the
atlantic monthly
for more information on stephen
budianski visit his website at
dot
budianski.com